all right Ted thank you as we have
reported it's no secret that Nevada
State Police currently facing a staffing
crisis but for those currently on the
force the job must be done a news now
recently got the chance to ride along
with state troopers during one of their
busiest weekends Madison Kimbrough now
joining us live there the Desert Inn
overpass Madison has more
busy it was as this report you'll see
just
just any given night and the hard work
that goes along with cracking down on
these dangerous drivers
this is a 55 mile per hour Zone this
guy's doing State steady 81.
drivers driving while under the end
Moran sees daily the only reason I'm
stopping is for doing 81 and a 55 mile
per hour with radar detection in both
the front and back of Patrol Vehicles
many drivers slow down once they see
State Police but it's often too late as
troopers already have them locked in
their sights 8 news now got to ride
along during one of the busiest times of
year Super Bowl weekend and during that
hour we saw state troopers pull over two
drivers Trooper Moran sharing where he
sees the most Speeders highest speeds
are usually found on the 15 especially
coming into Las Vegas you know you start
seeing the lights in Vegas so it's like
like moths drawn to light you know just
past weekend alone a Nevada State Police
encountered 10 crashes 13 DUIs and two
wrong way drivers NSP Trooper Jason
barachuk says drivers need to be more
aware of who to reach out to when they
see crisis on our roadways what we're
seeing on our roads with the impairment
and the wrong ways if anyone spots a
wrong way driver or an impaired driver
dial Star and HP don't dial 9-1-1 star
and HP goes directly to our Dispatch
Center and that'll get a trooper
dispatch within minutes and just as we
were about to end our ride this happened
how much alcohol you had to drink
tonight
um
you didn't drink anything at all this
man eventually arrested for not only
driving under the influence of alcohol
and marijuana but also for outstanding
warrants in California
in 2022 nearly 400 people died on
Nevada's roadways and crashes where
impairment and speed were the top two
contributing factors an impairment
doesn't just mean that alcohol is
involved as anything that inhibits your
ability to drive a motor vehicle safely
reporting live Addison Kimbrough 8 News
Now